[Musique]
pas
hello bonjour à tous donc comme elle
vient de le dire je m'appelle dan
aultman je suis miniaturiste depuis 30
ans est également passionné d'effets
spéciaux au cinéma
évidemment étant donné que je suis
depuis 15 ans restaurateurs d'objets
spéciaux de cinéma pour les musées dans
le monde pour les studios dans le monde
et pour des réalisateurs
je parle d'effets spéciaux avant
l'époque du tout numérique
on va pas évidemment restaurer des
petits chiffres qui défilent
je vais d'abord vous parler de mon monde
miniature comment on devient
miniaturiste ça c'est en me pose souvent
cette question
c'est vrai qu'étant enfant tout de suite
j'ai été fasciné par l'art de la
miniature mon premier livre c'était les
aventures des disputes évidemment
gulliver s'est pas de sécu et j'ai fait
et venice pendant 20 ans mais même étant
ébéniste je voulais à tout prix faire
des meubles en miniature c'est ce que
j'ai commencé à faire je vais vous
parler après de la suite j'ai j'ai voulu
faire des intérieurs en miniature je me
suis dit il faut des mémoires
je suis allé par exemple trouver un lieu
étonnant hein un ancien tisseur de lyon
allait fermer son atelier je trouvais
important de reproduire son atelier de
tissage dans mon 3d à moi lorsque je
vais sur un lieu un grand bonheur vous
imaginez de rencontrer ces artistes
la personne avait 90 ans qui me fait
tout comprendre de cet atelier de
tissage
je fais un millier de photographies des
centaines de mesures et remettre nazaire
avec le maître au ruban à quatre pattes
quelquefois et puis aussi beaucoup de
croquis une semaine dans quête pour
après partir sur table architecture on
retrouve aux métiers d'autrefois et
reproduire pour la première fois avec
des petits bois j'ai fabriqué moi même
mes propres machines en miniature en
tant que ministre et me voici aussi à
ouvrir des fenêtres à travailler des
lumières et aussi beaucoup de travail
sur les métiers à tisser
vous imaginez ce que c'est le travail
sur les métiers à tisser pour donner
cette miniature que vous avez devant
vous cette miniature ses 60 cm de large
1 mètre de profondeur
il est important dans une miniature de m
les détails mais au fond les diplômes de
ceux de ce vieil homme
la plante verte le poêle à bois pour moi
reproduire une miniature c'est vous
inviter à l'est chez lui on va sculpter
très souvent des stucs on va mettre du
vrai vers plus modernes évidemment un
loft à brooklyn travailler sur les
pièces de nikki saint phalle andy warhol
peindre avec un pinceau aiguille vous
savez je pars avec un pinceau aiguille
c'est trois fois le sol dans le pinceau
aiguilles
voilà le résultat à la sortie aussi
important les petits magazines sur la
table américain tous les petits détails
qui font qu'on se retrouve à brooklyn
qui connait les bouchons lyonnais vous
avez déjà mangé dans les bouchons
lyonnais c'est pas rien quand même
ambiance chaleureuse des bouchons eh
bien je ferai mes tables en acajou je
ferai mes chaises vraiment en noyer et
si j'ai réussi ma miniature elle fait un
mètre de large à m de profondeur si j'ai
réussi ma miniature ce coup ci elle a
demandé un an de travail
tout à l'heure c'était sept mois de
travail si j'ai réussi ma miniature il y
aura la guitare à côté de la
cochonnaille est sans doute le musicien
va peut-être devenir nous casser les
pieds avec sa musique alors qu on
espérera manger tranquille et boire du
bon beaujolais
pourquoi pas s'amuser avec la fameuse
épicerie qui ferme à minuit avec toute
cette espèce de pagaille là dans ces cas
là je m'amuse beaucoup puisque le
moindre paquet de pâtes
il ya des milliers de petites pattes
dans le sachet transparent cdc un demi
millimètre chaque petit nouilles
ça c'est de l'amusement qu'on est
annoncée n'est ce pas l'école de nancy
vous connaissez la neuro ça ça a été ma
passion en tant que ministre et j'ai pas
eu de clientèle qui m'ont demandé de
l'art nouveau et donc par procuration la
miniature m'a servi à faire de l'art
nouveau avec le fameux restaurant
maxim's coucou me voilà le restaurant
maxime ces 15 mois de travail sous
concentration j'ai travaillé avec les
véritables porcelaine j'ai travaillé
avec les verres soufflés grave et même
les couverts sont en argent et puis les
fresques sont peintes à l'acrylique
toujours avec ce fameux pinceau
aiguilles
presque de mu chat comme connaissez etc
on peut travailler pour le musée de la
marine sur un gigantesque restaurant du
normandy très beau paquebot français
disparus 700 places quand même là 700
places 700 chaise à fabriquer un an de
travail aussi et puis on a reste on
arrête le faste j'aime aussi les lieux
abandonnés vous avez vu c'est lui
abandonné ils sont chaleureux ils sont
étonnants il ya il ya ce qu'on appelle
un art complètement involontaire du
temps qui passe les murs qui s'effrite
les la ferraille qui rougit il ya ce
côté
oui involontaire delà de l'atteinte
il ya le côté il ya la lumière qui tombe
heureusement la main vous permet de voir
que c'est une miniature cette lumière
qui tombe
l'atelier sans doute le bureau du patron
euros qui surveillait autrefois ses
ouvriers et puis ces mannequins
abandonné qui donne la sensation de vie
normalement
j'aime j'aime à les reproduire
fidèlement des lieux chargés de vie des
lieux on sent qu'il s'est passé beaucoup
de choses des lieux d'atmosphère quand
j'étais enfant là l'attraction de mon
oncle qui me disait va chercher les
oeufs sur le siège avant que les chiens
ne mange mais j'évolue à refaire une
espèce de mémoire cette traction
abandonné à la campagne la cave et
l'aide aujourd'hui ces pratiques les led
puisque je peux même mettre une balle à
deux allumés dans une vieille carte
d'autrefois et qui existe un théâtre
abandonné en espagne j'ai eu envie de
reproduire pour moi c'est ça
représentait beaucoup de choses qui se
sont passées dans ce théâtre et il est
abandonné mais il va renaître un jour
c'est un peu le le mouvement de la vie
je l' ai ressenti un peu commun comme
quelque chose de symbolique profondeur
j'adore les profondeurs profondeur des
archives 14 mille dossiers quand même
bonjour le travail quatorze mille
dossiers un peu la colle qui jouit là je
suis un petit peu déjà dans le cinéma je
me joue du cinéma profondeur d'une
cantine les savons jaune au fond et oui
vous avez tous connu le savon jaune pour
se laver les mains qui des fois était
pas très jaune à la sortie et on doit
pouvoir sentir les entendre je veux dire
quand on regarde une miniature on doit
pouvoir entendre le bruit des
fourchettes qui s'amplifie quand les
frites arrive pour les pour les lycées
les prisons c'est terrible pour préparer
cette prison est fermée aujourd'hui j'ai
voulu la faire en mémoire avant qu'elle
soit littéralement fermé un véritable
alcatraz en france alors ce qui est
important c'est que quand on fait une
miniature il ya la moitié du travail
le dortoir ses sept mois ouvrage la
moitié c'est tout ce qu'on voit les lits
les douches mais il ya une autre moitié
qui subliminal et qui est important
c'est que vous avez carrément le tuyau
du radiateur
vous avez sur la table de nuit vous avez
carrément les graffitis des élèves
ils ont laissé ça dans leur dos toi
c'est importante c'est ce qu'on appelle
les oeuvres la partie subliminal les
craquelures au mur le vieux boutons en
porcelaine d'autres fois c'est ça qui
est très important pour donner 100
sessions de vie parce que finalement
dans la vie tout n'est pas propre comme
un catalogue de 2 de déco les choses se
salissent les choses s'abîme des
atmosphères intéressante pourquoi pas
raizen là c'était assez amusant japon
j'ai dû attendre 15 jours que les
méditants zen s'en aille pour que je
puisse prendre des mesures je vous
emmène sous l'eau pourquoi pas dans des
cités et puis là un record de on va dire
de laisser aller de ma part seulement 15
jours pour faire la piscine on va passer
à la partie effets spéciaux de cinéma
imaginez en 88 moi moi qui suis
miniaturiste me dit m je veux rencontrer
à hollywood george lucas ce style go les
marchés sont tous ceux qui ont travaillé
sur les stars war je me dis il faut y
aller
c'est là où je dis souvent à mes propres
élèves parce que je donne des cours
je leur dis quand il arrive un moment où
vous n'avez rien à perdre tout à gagner
c'est le moment où il faut avoir du
culot il faut foncer
j'ai écrit j'ai été très bien reçu là
bas pour la première fois en 1988 en 90
y avait une belle exposition star wars
après en france imagine estime que
démarre cette semaine me reconnaissait
facilement la petite delorean qui a
servi un retour vers le futur pour moi
j'étais comme un enfant dans le bonheur
le plus total il m'est arrivé donc une
espèce d' aventure
quand vous rencontrez martin reza martin
visage vous la même ici ce soir
uniquement en photo malheureusement mais
martin reiser c'est quand même un gars
qui travaille surtout les stars war
assault actuelle
martin les arbres connais assez des
pièces de star wars on les reconnaît
c'est bien voilà ce que vous voyez en ce
moment il va pas me dire parce qu'il a
peur que je le répète il va pas me dire
ce qu elle en train de faire pour le
prochain star wars pour reconnaissez
évidemment game of thrones le marcheur
blanc exceptionnel est aussi une pièce
de harry potter un gobelin beaucoup de
travail restauration d'objets de cinéma
je disais une chauve-souris assez
impressionnant là en ce moment si vous
allez sur lyon j'espère vous allez y
aller
en ce moment je suis en train de
restaurer une chauve-souris cas servi
dans batman forever 1995 voyez c'est
très abîmé le latex désagrège au bout de
8 ans 10 ans le latex meurent parce que
la tessiture et d'un arbre c'est quelque
chose de naturel et il sait font cette
chauve-souris et sauver ça y est on va
la mettre au plafond et elle fait 5
mètres d'envergure est assez
impressionnante
jean pierre jeunet le papa d'amélie
poulain n'a pas fait qu amélie poulain
il a fait aussi un formidable alien
resurrection numéro quatre et nous a
donné pour notre bonheur à restaurer un
des aliens d' alien resurrection 8
mètres de long 300 kg l'heure le
mammouth
ici nous avons dans la famille gremlins
je veux la fille vous reconnaissez
différentes petites choses et là vous
voyez ce que c'est la nasa la salle
petite peste ce qui le monde des
animatroniques sachez que dans un film
par exemple le film les deux frères jean
jacques annaud et bien il ya des
véritables tir mais à un moment donné
quand un enfant s'approche trop près du
tir
et bien c'est un faux tir magnifique
comme celui là qui est entièrement
automatisé animatroniques on appelle ça
et qui va éviter tout danger dans
flipper le dauphin le dauphin qui est
échouée sur la plage on va pas embêter
un vrai dauphin c'est un an
un dauphin entièrement mécanique voilà
pour ou entièrement mécanique loricourt
mier qui travaillent dans les ateliers
avec moi est en train de restaurer toute
la mécanique
vous avez enfin c'est mon petit chouchou
quand même très ceratops de jurassic
park c'est pas rien quand même
aujourd'hui il vit à lyon le tricératops
de jurassic pas vous à vous rappeler de
cette image là les prothésistes sont
exceptionnels
vieillir quelqu'un qui est jeunes
masqués michael jackson qui va danser
permettre de faire une plaie hachoir ce
n'est guère et puis l'une des plus
célèbres c'est robin williams maquillé
en mai six doubtfire wind est la
meilleure maquilleuse américaine l'avait
maquiller il y a six heures de
maquillage pour obtenir une minute de
tournage c'est pas rien quand même ici
en atelier voici l'un des sous ça est en
pleine restauration de cette petite
merveille donc mis 6 doubtfire regarder
ça la jeune fille vient juste de mettre
sur ses cheveux blonds un petit casque
en à bonnet de bain petit l'oreille qui
démarre mais regardez ça voilà trois
heures après vous voyez la folie du
maquillage voilà avant après 2 comment
ne pas tomber émerveillé quand vous
allez dans les studios vous voyez toutes
sortes de choses il n'y a pas plus
émouvant plus plus fort en en créativité
que les studios de cinéma ils savent
travailler des résines ça travailler le
métal le bois les silicones et ils
savent tout faire c'est un niveau
exceptionnel je dis souvent que les
réalisateurs et les et les producteurs
ont beaucoup de chance d'avoir les
artistes comme ça et c'est ce qui est
exceptionnel à leur service très souvent
a très souvent quand on met des artistes
ont quitté le cinéma pour mener leur
propre carrière et croyez bien qu'ils
sont dans les biennales à l'heure
actuelle et qu'il faut absolument
merveille à leur propre compte et ils
sont de grands artistes
une miniature je n'ai pas fait voir tout
à l'heure pour revenir à ma passion de
miniatures là j'ai mis un an de travail
pour faire allusion de l'histoire
naturelle
ah oui voici les députés je vous disais
tout à l'heure
mon obsession comment je me suis
incrusté là dedans il y en a quand
auront pris on travaille toujours avec
le fonds vert et c'est pour vous dire
que tout miniature procède à une
incrustation grâce aux fonds vers le
fonds versés comme la météo vous savez
le ver est éliminée c'est de la
transparence après on peut faire des
collages tant qu'on veut contre avec le
fonds vert sur beaucoup de pièces nous
en resterons beaucoup et ça c'est le
dernier blade runner qui vient de sortir
voyez il ya encore des miniatures
n'allez pas croire que tout est en
numérique formidable travail de
miniatures des nerfs dernier blade
runner époque et cinquième élément
bruce willis était en effet dans une est
toujours le vrai véhicule
la vraie batmobile le vrai taxi mais
pour les images lointaine on va à la
main
nature évidemment pour ne pas faire trop
de risques aussi mais droner d'autres
fois ça c'est pas rien c'est à midi que
ça le fameux spyder avec harrison ford
en miniature à l'intérieur batman sur la
lune évidemment le film moon vous ne
connaissez peut-être pas mais il faut le
voir c'est un film qui est superbe
si on la lune et leurs ovaires est assez
formidable hélicoptère de james bond
hélicoptère de vertical limit
voilà beaucoup de choses qui passa dans
nos ateliers et qui sont notre bonheur
et quelquefois un vaisseau et monumental
là il fait 500 kg il faut un grutage
exceptionnelle pour pouvoir la mener
dans une salle et puis quelques fois
important la miniature de personnage
jack sparrow johnny depp et johnny depp
il est dans pirates des caraïbes sur un
chariot complètement enflammé et là ça
commence à chauffer à ses fesses comme
ça évidemment c'est une figurine qu'il
représente absolument sûr un petit
chariot miniature enflammé qui va
prendre le relais à l'image de manière à
ce que ça risque pas trop pour l'acteur
ils sont trois acteurs connus dans du
style hoffman il va monter dans un
bathyscaphe on voit la grue qui le
descend dans l'eau comme ça ça n'ira pas
plus loin
en réalité c'est cette miniature
derrière qui prend le relais avec les
petits personnages de des acteurs qui
sont reproduits en tout petit à
l'intérieur voilà pour moi l'art de la
miniature c'est quelque chose de
passionnant et je vais vous présenter
maintenant un ami exceptionnel c'est
simon vice encore un très grand c'est le
chef maquettiste de wes anderson
c'est quand même pas rien vous avez
connu une rampe et en paix granby
n'apaise cotelle l'île aux chiens qui va
sortir en ce moment qui est déjà sortie
et donc ils travaillent essentiellement
comme chef maquettiste
il faut toujours procéder par un dessin
on fait un dessin et après c'est parti
c'est comme pour les miniatures
il ya beaucoup de travail après sur la
table on commence la matière des
milliers des millions même de petits
morceaux qui sont associés pour créer là
une sorte de ballon dirigeable qui a
servi dans les trois mousquetaires ce
ballon dirigeable c'est un peu c'est un
peu à la jules verne c'est mignon comme
tout ça fait rêver
c'est un petit peu bizarre un maître un
zeppelin sur un galion du 15e siècle
mais les américains sont capables de ça
on est bien d'accord
j'ai compté il y avait bien le bon
nombre de mons côté travail assez
important on a on a aussi en mille
morceaux et on l'a entièrement restauré
ce zeppelin voyez il est très beau et il
fait ça m de longueur
[Musique]
granby la peste hôtel impressionnant 5
mètres de long presque 4 mètres de
hauteur
là c'est pareil un travail et non alors
wes anderson adore la miniature c'est un
des rares réalisateurs qui aiment les
miniatures même et il veut qu'on voit
que c'est une miniature parce que c'est
un peu comme un personnage de son film
il aime il aime que ça soit visible si
ça si ça va très bien un téléphérique
qui monte dans la montagne et mais lui
va faire en sorte que sa chronique un
petit peu voyez pas ce qu'il veut qu'
une petite anomalie qui fasse bien voir
que les artistes miniaturiste étaient au
boulot et simon reiss le voilà devant
son enfant sa formidable oeuvre qui a
demandé messieurs dames quatre mois de
travail à 15 personnes
et croyez bien qu'il travaille vite je
vous parlais de batman tout à l'heure
j'aime bien cette séquence
chaque fois qu'il ya de l'eau messieurs
dames chaque fois qu'il ya de la fumée
et des flammes et il faut que les
miniatures soit grosses boucles à
l'échelle correspondent à vouvoyer
batman contre son ennemi le joker est
bien va se battre batmobile m'a
rencontré un camion et un boulot
complètement dingue
une scène avec un couloir géant c'est
simplement un moment de choc ils vont
s'entrechoquer ils vont se taper ans
envoyé la batmobile importance qu'elle a
un matériel spécialement fabriqué
beaucoup de ces faits à la soudure à
tous ces chariots qui qui qui met la
caméra il ya une caméra qui doublent une
caméra qui regardent en face
et voilà la scène ces dames cette scène
impressionnant
neuf secondes à l'image pratiquement un
million de dollars la scène
voilà c'est ça la magie du cinéma
quand vous rentrez dans à new york ou à
los angeles
et vous vous avez devant vous subitement
times square en miniature et là c'est
complètement émouvant où on trouvait des
immeubles de trois mètres de haut vous
enjambez des taxis jaunes comme ça et
vous êtes au mini vont pas vous dire
pourquoi c'est faire mais c'est ça qui
est pour moi la magie du cinéma qui vaut
vraiment le coup aussi de d'être vus par
le public
parce que derrière il ya des artistes
exceptionnels on va faire de la vraie
vapeur pour iron mines
en 1986 il y a eu à paris une locomotive
qui a défoncé la gare la gare de
montparnasse elle est tombée dans la rue
il ya eu un seul poignet foulé un rap
rassurez vous eh bien ils ont dit new
deal studios ont dit on va reproduire la
scène finalement là c'est pareil c'est
quinze personnes pendant sept mois de
travail pour reproduire regarder
impressionnant échelle 1 8e le fonds
ouverts pour tous qui va circuler les
acteurs sur fond vert qui auront
rendez-vous et des petites marques au
sol avec la les images prennent pour
être incrustée dans la seine est
important c'est des milliers de bagages
des milliers de petits détails des
tissus des valises
regardez le travail voilà et ils sont
les seuls new deal studio à los angeles
à être capable de faire cette scène à la
perfection ce qui est important c'est
que ça coûte des fortunes et ils n'ont
pas le droit à l'erreur il peut pas la
recommencer parce que tout était ce
quinté au bout d'un moment
et puis pour terminer pour terminer je
vais me faire vraiment agacé à lyon si
je rentre sans vous parler de ma chérie
donc on est depuis un an est en train de
restaurer la reine alien la fameuse
reine alien c'est le dernier grand
automates géant il ya eu le tricératops
jeu dont il ya eu le t-rex de jurassic
park dernier
gigantesque automates robots et le
dernier aussi c'est une fantastique and
aliens je me suis dit il faut sauver
cette bête parce qu'elle est autant ses
lèvres que marilyn monroe ou que les
beatles on n'a pas le droit de la
laisser partir
on appelait un banquier on a dépensé et
on sauve à la reine depuis un an et demi
elle est pas tout à fait fini patrick
lowe dix spéciales y compris sa liste en
robotique et alain julié voyage en train
de découper la pause c'est pas du
poisson et la 200 kg de peau encore une
fois cette peau a été traitée à la
seringue elle a été autopsié pour sauver
ce latex qui se désagrège et petit à
petit vous avez la bête qui devant le
public les et se met en route pour moi
c'est un grand bonheur
on a encore beaucoup de soucis parce que
c'est plus facile d'aller trouver
comment faire un far aux pruneaux sur
internet que comment restaurer une reine
alien canton des miniaturistes on est
bien d'accord et mais on y arrive quand
même et heureusement on est aidé par pas
mal de gens du cinéma qui passe pour
nous donner des conseils et pour nous
dire souvent ce qu'on n'aurait pas dû
faire voilà donc je suis un peu dépassé
mais c'est fini
royer la peau c'est assez immense on est
en train de fabriquer tout ça mais je
voulais vous l'a fait roi rhin pour pas
avoir des problèmes au retour si j'ai
pas parlé à nancy de ma chérie ça va
faire des histoires
voilà bien si à tous
[Applaudissements]